hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how are you doing season seven of
fortnight battle royale is coming to a
close so now is a good time to look back
at the easter eggs those cultural
references and some in-game events which
brought the community closer together
well until apex legends turned up
quickly move on season 7 started over
the Christmas period on December 6th
2018 running until the winter season
ended on February 28 2019 the theme was
you better watch out which in itself is
an easter egg to the song Santa Claus is
coming to town
the introductory video for the new
season used a pseudo stop-motion
animation effect to look like old
festive children's TV movies the most
obvious is Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer first released in 1964 but it's
been rerun every Christmas ever since
the battle pass once again gave us a
bounty to grind for with many items
referencing pop culture kicking off
right away with the multi level
character links the character was
immediately claimed by streamer kitty
plays who bears a striking resemblance
to Lynx she goes for those cat-eared
hats generally she has the same clothing
and even the glasses match up to hers so
you can understand this reaction I think
she has the right to hyperventilate you
right now pardon I hope she means
figuratively because if not that is
nasty as the Lynx character evolves she
takes on the armor effects of Marvel's
Black Panther a movie about superheroes
but look at that mask that she has it's
inspired by the mask of the predator it
even has the braided ponytail in the
same style as predators dreadlocks one
more final layer to the costume nod to
the DC Universe the unlockable emote cat
flip is an homage to Catwoman from the
1992 version of Batman meow if you've
watched my videos for a while you know
that I've always wanted a hamster pet
for a backlink we only bloody got it in
season 7 look at this little cute booger
and it gets better he's available in hot
pink awesome art what moving on the
abominable snowman known as Trog was
released in the season 7 battle puss
he's another nod to the stop
animation we talked about earlier not
only that but he's bug-eyed look from
taking a fall in those TV movies he's
represented almost perfectly at night
one of the key places in that story the
yetis cave is lovingly recreated in
fortnight a reference to 1964 pretty
damn impressive the battle pass
introduced something players have asked
for for a long time weapon skins known
as wraps sadly there's no hot pink
option but beggars can't be choosers I
suppose epic if you're listening come on
sort it out at the moment it's only me
and Bret the Hitman Hart who's repping
pink we need help i need stop the video
here there's been an update whilst I'm
making this video hot pink wraps are on
the way but the strangest thing is they
are designed to replicate WVUE wrestler
Bret the Hitman Hart attire even his
broken heart wings are in the design
anyway back to the video new mechanics
were introduced in season 7 which I'll
be honest I hated with a passion
the bloody storm wings that could run
structures and fly away unharmed caused
many people to take a break from what
night on a personal level hopefully they
will be taken out in a future update but
each to their own maybe you love them
season 7 also gave us zip lines for
quick travel and for a brief period of
time a sword
became available to murder everyone it
didn't last too long but for a brief
period of time something more powerful
than panels existed in fortnight so does
that sword remind you of anything yeah
it is indeed the infinity blade from
that game I can't remember the title off
sorry about the joke sadly this does tie
into the iOS game being removed from the
App Store in December 2018 due to
updating issues for new tech its last
hurrah was in for tonight
lifting the embedded sword is taken from
an old romanticized story of King Arthur
and the iconic moment he pulled out the
sword from the stone oh that reminds me
the pose that you hit when lifting that
slab of steel that's the pose Luke
Skywalker hits on the 1977 Star Wars
poster a complete with bolts of light
one more huge easter egg in the battle
past and it arrives at tier 100 the ice
king
he shares many similarities to roblox
characters which is a great way to get
those players to move over to fortnight
but any world of warcraft veteran will
recognize the ice king as the lich king
from that saga he ties in to the story
big time involving the prisoner too so
hold on let's put a pin in that and
we'll quickly look at the map updates
during season 7 so the new season
brought over a freaking iceberg to smash
into the island this changed huge
portions making the island bigger in the
process flesh factory was obliterated
left in ruins and replaced with happy
hamlet a little European town using many
assets from save the world the snow
froze many areas of the map including
the waterfall at Viking Valhalla and
completely submerged greasy Grove under
a block of ice by the way how cool does
it look in the outward-bound star after
smashing the walls freakin brilliant
touch the chair sculpture above young de
yard became a sleigh over season 7 and
at the other side of the map the
architect's house changed from wood to
brick maybe in future seasons it'll
finally be completed up in the same
region we were introduced to the block
which gave creators a chance to be
featured in the game I'm gutted to say
risky reels was deleted from existence
in that process let's start a petition
bring back risky reels or we riot a
random turtle appeared above lonely
lodge and all the corrupted areas from
last season began to grow over we even
had another restaurant join the food
fight this time an ice cream parlor over
by the track back down in the snow a
hidden bunker was found mirroring the
warning wailing woods may be a fast
travel point for next season we shall
see a yellow submarine surfaced too in
homage to the Beatles
Ashi grammar about them she'll love them
all the new content brought us Explorer
outposts around the island rock
sculptures appeared and faces could be
found hidden in the world many resembles
Pokemon characters but I think that was
coincidental and cuttingly the castle
above haunted hills began to crumble my
safe easy win landing spot is no more
speaking of destruction the building
until tea towers you know the one that
is destroyed more times and fought might
get sued it finally has a permanent
residence a TV station no less complete
with hulking satellite now we have a
reason to keep an eye on the TVs around
the world
but let's be serious for a moment those
earthquakes will likely destroy that
building yet again and I can't wait now
we have everything in place we can look
at the story of season seven but just
before we do that I wanted to take a
moment to get these legends on screen
they used code and amaru in the shop
which has made this video possible this
wouldn't be here without those people
honestly I know I say this a lot but
without you guys
I am nothing thank you so much for
supporting me right before I start
crying let's move on to the story of
season seven the story loading screens
depict the new explorers to the island
doing exactly that exploring with zeniff
searching for the abominable snowman
lynx is seen designing weaponry and
costumes which may have been distributed
by Santa and his robots during week
three one of those gifts happens to be a
hoverboard which sadly never appeared in
season 7 that we have hope it may come
soon week five showed us that the Yeti
was happily in hiding before our
attentions were once again taken back to
the food fight which rumbled on Four
Seasons check out the pizza pit
character spying in the background week
seven is where things became interesting
the Ice King was suddenly awakened by
the thawing ice his plan was pretty
simple to freeze the entirety of the
island gathering up his strength he
cocooned himself in a sphere of ice but
before he could execute that plan the
snow around polar peak melted just
enough to let us see inside the castle
evidence of an argument could be seen in
the courtroom a chair flung on the
ground and mysterious symbols upon each
chair in the dungeon a shocking sight
could be witnessed a frozen prisoner lay
dormant the Ice King attempted to freeze
the entire island once he had enough
power and it looked like this
[Music]
he also summons the ice legions which
kept us all on our toes but it was
already too late for the ice king the
prisoner had escaped slowly he regained
his strength which looks to be fire in
nature first he unlocked his abilities
by taking off those shackles
then he thawed the island again evolving
his fire appearance banishing the husks
once again as the season draws to a
close the prisoner looks to restore
balance but what will happen next I
think we're getting a volcano I'll
explain more in another video but for
now let's just stick with the facts but
I would absolutely love to know what you
think is going to happen next so I've
said the ice king is a take on the Lich
King from World of Warcraft did you know
that in that story the Lich King held a
character called bolvar fordragon
prisoner and when you look at his
character art it's easy to see the
similarities in WoW for Dragon was a
loyal paladin dedicated to taking down
the hog and the scourge but during a
battle bolívar dies to a hard gas attack
but moments before his death the red
dragon uses fire to cleanse the area now
dead he's imprisoned by the lich king
who tortures him in his icy lair long
story short the alliance kills the lich
king but the kicker is that there always
needs to be a lich king and Ice King so
bolívar now infused with the red dragons
heat sits atop of the ice throne sworn
to keep balance in the land with his
uncorruptible soul for Dragon then
covers himself in eternal ice never to
be awakened again you can definitely see
where the influence has come from but
it's bloody interesting isn't it and to
finish up at polar peak in the dungeon
area are many tools of torture which
back up this story but hidden away are
these dragon eggs this looks to be
another game of Thrones reference and
the dragon eggs seen in the dungeons in
the castle down in King's Landing and we
all know what happens when they finally
make contact with fire
[Music]
it's me me time there's only one name
this season it was in the battle pass
the F icon calling for F sin chat is
something which we've seen seemingly
forever but it all began life thanks to
Call of Duty and this scene in which the
player has to press f to pay respects to
a fallen comrade let's finish with item
shop Easter eggs and references during a
challenge late in the season the storm
wings play ride of the Valkyries this
was popularized by the movie Apocalypse
Now and is synonymous with flights going
into battle
the ground-pound emote is how much to
all superhero landings my favorite is
this in Deadpool superhero landing yeah
that's really hard on your knees the
showstopper emote is an old reference to
a sketch from Chris Farley trying out to
be in the Chippendales to a male
strippers by the way Chris has the
perfect body look at the definition the
marsh walk tribute to marshmallow
includes John Cena's calling card you
can't see me a frozen princess was added
midseason in homage to yet another
Disney property frozen late on in the
season it was possible to unlock little
gingy based on the gingerbread character
in Shrek especially the bloody annoying
voice this bobbing emote is taken from
Will Ferrell's iconic head bobbing dance
from Saturday Night Live a sketch which
became a film called night at the
Roxbury the final update to the season
gave us a character design to look like
Hugh Hefner he was the founder of
Playboy magazine and had a lifestyle
about him sharing the love here
iconically wore red robes with either a
captain sailing hat or a trilby and now
he's a llama Renoir Tate
hey who did it and to finish off there
are a few more things that happen in
season 7 we all saw in the new year
together do you remember and one of the
first fully online concerts happened
with marshmallow returning to fortnight
gigging to over 10 million people sadly
I can't use the music for copyright
reasons so here's my music instead yeah
this is better and that was season 7 in
a nutshell I imagine from PlayStation
granade it's been an absolute pleasure
please think about using my code as a
Mario in the port night shop and in
return I will continue to cover
fortnight that sound like a good deal
anyway it's been a pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]